[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
we have a suspect in custody and justice
will be served authorities announced an
arrest in the shocking shooting
of two sheriff's deputies it turns out
they already had their man locked up
plus one of the officers charged with
killing george floyd
says new evidence could vindicate him
and
causing arguments in the case of a man
accused of cooking his mother's head
on the stove over thanksgiving weekend
nobody else had a reason to do this
long crime daily covers court cases from
coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everybody to law and crime daily
i'm aaron keller along with brian
buckmeyer and terry austin as usual
let's begin in tennessee right off the
top with closing arguments in the murder
trial of 32 year old joel guy
jr he's accused of stabbing his parents
to death on thanksgiving weekend
testimony revealed that the parents were
making plans to retire
and were going to stop supporting the
defendant financially they'd been paying
for his apartment authorities found a
notebook riddled with what prosecutors
say were plans by the defendant to kill
his parents and dismember their bodies
including using chemicals one of the
passages seen here
saying get rid of bodies inside house my
dna already there
flush chunks down toilet not garbage
disposal and
get plastic sheeting for disposal
process
and then there's this police body camera
footage recorded after a co-worker
called 9-1-1
to report something suspicious may have
happened to the victims
authorities say they found the head of
the defendant's mother cooking
inside the pot on the stove upstairs
several officers found
severed hands in a gruesome and
disgusting scene
let's head straight to terry austin with
the state's closing argument terry
erin prosecutors say the defendant
committed these murders beyond
any reasonable doubt and reminded the
jury of what the state called
guy's book of premeditation
the same book that has his dna on it
essentially the writings what they do is
they corroborate
everything that's on the crime scene so
everything he set out to do
he did get rid of the bodies inside of
the house
the proof is showing that he did that
ladies and gentlemen or at least
attempted to
get carving knives to make small pieces
get knives because they're quiet get
multiple of them
get plastic sheeting for the disposal
process get bleach denature proteins
get plastic bin for denaturation process
turn heat up to 90 to melt fingerprints
and dry everything
turn heater up as high as it goes to
speed decomposition
okay well we know what he wants to
decompose uh the dis articulated the
brutalized bodies of his parents that
are in an asset acidic based fluid
prosecutors say they've proven that joel
guy jr intentionally killed his mother
and father
so with regard to joel guy's senior
we know that he was executed in the
exercise room
with apparent signs of struggle the
blood patterns
on the walls there's clearly a struggle
in this room
going down the hallway we're
investigating mccord and ballard were
able to see
the severed hands in a praying-like
position
of joe guy senior she was lured upstairs
up the stairwell and brutally attacked
blood present
on the way up the stairs likely the
result of
joel guy jr bringing his mother's
decapitated head down the stairwell
ultimately putting it in a stockpot and
boiling it for days
before it's ultimately discovered well
terry the top charge here is first
degree murder so the state has to prove
the killing was premeditated and
intentional how did the state do
in the closings as to the law and to the
style of the argument
erin as far as i was concerned this is a
bases loaded
home run out of the park they had an
opening statement which was detailed and
organized they had witnesses which were
introduced to establish
certain pieces of evidence and they did
that and they had a closing with the
powerpoint
that showed all of the relevant
information so absolutely the
prosecution did its job and they did it
well
boy a home run basis loaded that's got
to drive fear into the mind of the
public defender brian buckmeyer walk us
through some of the defense closing
argument here
the defense argued that the testimony
from their relatives presented a
portrait of a happy family
the holiday weekend the killings
occurred in other words
they say the defendant is not the killer
that weekend joel guy was outgoing
friendly and happy in a way
michelle tyler had never seen him before
outgoing friendly and happy
that was not a man about to commit a
homicide outgoing
friendly and happy you saw it in the
picture from the
from the front porch smiling
happy that's who joel guy was that
weekend
he was not someone planning on
committing a murder
his father was stabbed at least 41 times
his mother at least 32 times that is
anger
that is rage that is not
happy and outgoing
we heard family testimony that they plan
to cut him off financially
at christmas this was not christmas this
was not
when that was going to occur that's why
we have to look at
every fact to see if this adds up
the defense also argued the authorities
failed to test evidence for dna
including the mother's clothes the
defense also backtracked on the
source of the defendant's injuries which
at one point where they agreed occurred
during a fight between the defendant and
his parents
clearly we know at some point he hurt
his hand but that doesn't tell us
when or how he hurt his hand the fact
he's getting medicine for his hand
does not tell us anything about the
homicide and
again on the dna they get to pick and
choose what they tested
kim lowe decided she just wasn't going
to test some things that she decided
weren't relevant for example
the kitchen glove i said what about the
kitchen glove
in the master bathroom do you cook in
the master bathroom
you do dishes in the master bathroom and
that's where the bodies were
don't need to test that that's not going
to tell us anything at all
okay brian i was surprised about what
the defense said there because they
stipulated that the hand was injured in
some kind of altercation with the
parents and then they said
we don't know why or how it happened can
we reconcile that at all
i think that's a defense attorney
attempting to slide in some amount of
reasonable doubt
but like a mosquito trying to bite an
elephant i don't think the prosecution
was really worried about that
because they had so much more evidence
that they can point towards his guilt
so it's possible the prosecutor could
have wedged an objection of some sort in
there or at least argued against it but
they didn't because
there's so much else going on here so
the so-called happy family photo
argument what about all the testimony
about rancor over money
yeah i don't really like that argument i
don't like many of the defense
attorney's arguments here but of course
i don't have the file in front of me
i don't know what he's constrained to
argue with but there just seems to be so
many missed opportunities by the defense
that he could have woven in some amount
of reasonable doubt here
well the state has the burden of proof
of course in a case like this any
criminal case so the state gets the last
word
during a powerful rebuttal prosecutors
pointed to a possible motive
and to means she paid for the tubs
but she and her husband disintegrated in
she worked all those years at jacob
engineering
to put him up to keep him in his
lifelong whatever program he's in at lsu
she wasn't going to cut him off oh my
goodness
she gave him everything he wanted and
then she had the nerve
the nerve to tell him that
they retired and needed a break
and still ahead here on law and crime
daily the forensic evidence in the joel
guy jr case which allowed the prosecutor
to make some of those claims
also later on can evidence of a police
officer's good deeds in the past
and with his acquittal in the alleged
murder of george floyd we discussed the
law behind an interesting tactical move
back now to forensic evidence in the
murder case against joel guy jr who
stands accused of killing his parents
a medical examiner testified that jill
guy senior's body was so heavily damaged
that the
expert could only give an approximation
of his injuries
even some of the arms mr guy's arms were
down to bone and some of the bone had
begun to dissolve
there could have been more wounds so the
numbers of wounds that i give
is an at least number meaning
so much of the tissue was gone so much
of the skin was gone
that it's impossible for me to give an
exact counting
and on the skin of his back he had
what i identified as 34 sharp force
injuries associated with these stab
wounds i identified
injuries to the liver lungs
and kidneys and ribs this diagram
demonstrates that virtually all the skin
had been dissolved away
on mr guy's the front of his torso
and that his arms were disarticulated
and his legs were disarticulated and his
head was skeletonized does this indicate
that
mr guy was assaulted both from the front
and the back your findings
yes this guy's head of course was found
in a pot on the kitchen stove
and the rest of her body parts were in
her bathroom
investigators had to piece them together
to perform her autopsy
her head was completely severed from her
body
her arms were disarticulated at the
shoulders
and her legs were disarticulated at the
knees
so in comparison to mr guy who had his
legs disarticulated at the hips
mrs guy's um legs were
at the knee so her her thighs were still
intact her thighs were still attached
onto her body but her head was
completely severed and her arms were
completely severed
miss guy had multiple sharp force
injuries on her back
she had at least 25 and again i'm
having to do a little bit of a hedge
because of the the the
degree to which the remains were altered
they
included injuries to the heart
so the right ventricle or the right side
of her heart
the aorta in her abdomen both lungs were
injured
the left kidney the liver
she also had five stab wounds that were
relatively superficial on her buttock as
well
this is horrible to listen to terry but
look this is a real life trial
the state's going for murder one here
did the state meet its burden of proof
in this case you think
absolutely aaron i think the prosecution
successfully demonstrated beyond a
reasonable doubt beyond
any doubt that joel got murdered his
parents he dismembered their bodies
there was a plethora of evidence there
was dna there were receipts
there was witness testimony and the most
incriminating evidence was the fact that
this notebook
outlined the plan and the motive for the
murder and remember terry the
jury is seeing a lot more than we're
showing here
absolutely thank goodness we're not
seeing it i don't think i could stand it
because
the head and the pot is the worst part
and my understanding is they saw some of
that at least
yeah it's it's really bad here now brian
tactically was it smart for the
defendant
not to take the witness stand in his own
defense here probably the smartest thing
he's done in the last four years because
the potential for
impeachment if you just look at a loan
he testified in the hearing
and he gave one version as to how he got
the injuries but ended up
flipping and there was a stipulation
that he actually got those injuries from
an altercation with his parents
that impeachment alone would have buried
him and any other one that would have
come up would have definitely hurt his
case a skilled prosecutor would have
basically forced him to go
bit by bit through everything they
thought he did and he would have been
stuck
trying to answer it well when we come
back here on law and crime daily i look
forward to key questions which may be
answered by the release of grand jury
recordings
in the police shooting of briana taylor
and we're also taking a look at
new court papers which outline a
possible defense for one of the
minneapolis officers accused of
murdering george floyd
more analysis is right after this
i'm not always listening i'm not i'm not
we've all seen that disturbing body
camera footage of george floyd's
struggling with minneapolis police
officers before he died in custody
but we're now learning more about the
defense for those officers
going to trial for playing an alleged
role in george floyd's alleged
murder court papers filed this week
revealed that one of the officers
charged is trying to introduce body
camera video
of an unrelated good deed thomas lane's
attorneys say they have a recording of
lane helping a homeless black man one
night
after the man's electric wheelchair
failed lane proceeded to assist the man
and ultimately walked pushing the
wheelchair
through a snow ice rain mixture in the
january winter cold
to the police precinct where the
gentleman could rest inside a warm
building
while his motorized wheelchair charged
this specific
instance of conduct of lane's character
will be strong circumstantial evidence
that lane
did not with criminal intent assist in
the murder of george floyd
brian from a legal perspective let's
first key in on those words criminal
intent what do they mean and why are
they important here
so i apologize for laughing because i
read this motion and it was
quite laughable when we were talking
about criminal intent it is broad but
we're really talking about the men's ray
of the mental
standpoint that a person would have to
commit a crime or not
so what they're trying to say is by
doing this good deed for this
handicapped african-american male
he obviously could not have had the
intent to kill george floyd a very
separate and distinct
act so terry generally prosecutors can't
use character evidence to try to prove a
defendant
is a bad person and therefore more
likely to have committed
the crime charge but defendants can
raise
evidence of their own character but if
they do so it's usually dangerous
explain why
well it is dangerous aaron and this is a
prosecutor's dream come true
if the defense opens the door by
introducing
good character evidence well the
prosecution can walk right through that
door and demonstrate
bad character evidence of any sort
whatsoever for the most part
so while there doesn't seem to be any
prior complaints against lane
they can look at any other bad deeds
that he has done
and bring that into evidence so it
wasn't a good idea as far as i'm
concerned
brian buckmeyer when you said this was
laughable take us
inside the
opinions inside your head let me just
put it that way all right so there's two
ways you can argue this
you have to show that the two incidences
are so similar that you can
events some sort of evidence that they
have a a
mindset for peacefulness now think of it
logically
what the defense is saying here is that
yeah one time i held down a black man
and killed him with a
aid of another officer but on another
time i helped a black person who was
handicapped get to somewhere warm
there's no similarities there it's not
close enough and it's ridiculous on its
face
look it's highly possible the judge
might turn around and say this is just
not even relevant it doesn't even pass
the bar of relevance
to get into a case like this we'll wait
and see how the ruling turns out
and when we come back two sheriff's
deputies on the west coast are shot in
their own patrol car
now the authorities say their main
suspect is a man already
in custody that and more is right after
the break
[Music]
grand jury recordings are due to be
released by the end of the day on friday
in the police shooting death of brianna
taylor
some of the key questions include did
the grand jury consider homicide or
manslaughter charges regarding briana
taylor's death
how did the prosecutors explain the law
of self-defense and
how much of the recordings won't be
released due to privacy concerns
attorney ben crump represents brianna
taylor's family he spoke with me
recently about his hopes
as more information is due to become
public
do you fear that the authorities could
use the redactions to hide anything that
you need to know as part of your own
investigation or that the public needs
to know
to make sense of this and that's always
a concern
transparency is the key the problem
is that there is mistrust between
law enforcement and minority communities
and the solution is transparency plus
accountability
equals trust think about all the ways
they tried to cover up this case and
sweep it under the rug
where they said that there was no forced
entry
even though we know they busted in
brianna's front door to gain
entry and they said that there were no
injuries
even though brianna taylor's body was
mutilated with six bullets
while she was in her underwear and the
sanctity of her own apartment
killed by the police and let's head now
to los angeles where a suspect is under
arrest for allegedly ambushing two
deputies
the los angeles county sheriff says
36-year-old deonte lee murray walked up
to the deputies last month
and shot them while they were sitting in
their patrol vehicle
investigators believe the suspect drove
past the deputies multiple times that
night
both deputies are at home recovering the
sheriff says murray has a long criminal
history
and is affiliated with gangs he was
arrested two weeks ago for a separate
carjacking which ended after a nine hour
standoff
at the time the sheriff's office said
murray was not a suspect
in the shooting of the deputies now they
say there's evidence linking him
to both cases the forensic firearms
report was completed
and published by the sheriff's
department crime lab
this compared ballistic evidence from
the scene of the attempted murder on the
deputies
to the pistol which was discarded by
suspect murray during the pursuit
it was determined through ballistic
comparison that the pistol recovered
was the pistol used to shoot the transit
services deputies
additionally that pistol was
conclusively linked through forensic
testing
to suspect deonte murray
the firearm and evidence is described as
an 80 percenter
a ghost gun a 40 caliber pistol loaded
with eight rounds
five rounds short of its full capacity
there were five rounds fired at the
deputies the suspect pleaded not guilty
to the attempted murder of law
enforcement officers and to additional
charges in the carjacking case the los
angeles district attorney says the
defendant faces
up to life in prison if a jury convicts
him
at this point we've charged we have
deliberately chosen the charges that we
believe we can prove
as this case progresses you know in any
case of this nature
we expect more witnesses maybe will come
forward maybe more information
and uh if in fact we find
evidence to substantiate that this was
for the benefit of a gang then we would
amend the charges
what we did here is charge what we had
terry in order to get the level of
conviction they seek here in california
you have to have specific intent you
have to have a deliberate act and you
have to have melissa thor
a fourth thought can you walk us through
the law a little bit there
well aaron you know the prosecution has
to show that the defendant
actually tried to kill the victim here
but for reasons
not intended by the defendant for
reasons beyond his control
the resulting crime didn't occur so
basically
had the officers not assisted each other
had police not come to help them
they would have died so the intent is
there but the actual event did not occur
brian i got to key in on something that
the sheriff said there
use the phrase ballistics conclusive
conclusive ballistics
ballistics and weapons usually aren't
conclusive from an evidence standpoint
that's evidence that's open to a lot of
attack right exactly if we're talking
about is a 40 caliber gun and a 40
caliber bullet that could be any number
of guns that fire that bullet
what we really want to look at is the
striations of those bullet oftentimes
people say those striations leave what
would be like a fingerprint on that
the video we see is not id quality this
is not a case that is
that could is definitely proven beyond a
reasonable doubt there is some reason
without asking identification and that
could be a problem down the road
i only hope they got the right person
because he's going to feel a lot of the
weight of the law
certainly and thanks for joining us on
law and crime daily everybody appreciate
the insight thank you for being here we
will see you next time for our
discussions
i'm dan abrams and this is the lawn
crime network
the only 24 7 network with expert legal
analysis
and gavel to gavel live trial coverage
watch the law on crime network
today
[Music]
you